we're good right yeah we're good chin
got a little tiger thick going through
your through your veins it just hit the
veins i just came from the doctor old
doctor oh doctor
what's what procedure getting done now
just you know they're looking at them
with the baby bro
i got some nice tips on getting your
neck done i'm pretty happy with my body
right now are you yeah i went for a long
walk did some pull-ups and some dips a
long walk yeah yeah well you know you're
getting older wait you know you get
older if you refer to a walk as a
workout well did you eat your ten
thousand steps i know i'm getting older
because the old feet don't cooperate i
get oh they're hurting yeah bro when i
when i'm sitting down those golden
gooses aren't going to be nice to your
feet now they're too stiff no the third
is yeah that's why i stopped where am i
so so when i'm driving there's two real
flat shoes of [ __ ] your feet is that
what it is that's when you're driving
okay so i gotta get those installs
because when i'm driving
and then i get out of the car especially
because if i play tennis i've been
working out i got i i got some problems
in my ankles yeah you get those insoles
especially like especially the shoes you
wear yeah those adidas are all super
flat bottoms yeah yeah you get the
insole so i gotta get insoles
[ __ ] man you just get a couple of them
because then you can just entertain my
shoes you know i gotta do that
i'm doing that right after this because
i can't be having my feet my the old
feet in the morning too it's an issue oh
really daddy has problems getting older
because what that what daddy does lots
of exercise ages daddy plays tennis yeah
daddy does some running does some
walking run some hills
hey you don't do it you don't run okay i
don't know
don't run
but okay wait caveat hey also hold on
you've ran hillsborough before okay
you're not running hills everybody hold
on don't act like it's part of your pro
okay i do walk in the morning that's
that's right okay and then there's
there's a drive there's a there there
there is a hill yeah there's a hill that
i will sometimes the street there's a
little street that i said that's an
incline it's got an incline and we're
gonna call that a hill i feel like
that's okay that's fine and that's nice
i don't say i run hills sometimes
maybe if you've probably done it before
but it's not like a weekly regiment
thing is it
i love that
it's not though i had i did run the
other day to see what my wind was about
yeah yeah but would you do a sprint
i i just don't give a [ __ ] about running
yeah i've never been a run guy dude i
thought i was [ __ ] because i've been
sprinting forever and that tough mudder
i mean you're sprinting i was all right
though yeah you're all right it's the
bike and covey
you train yeah you train
if you keep working out i mean you know
i'll tell you what gives your daddy
energy if you get me drinking good wine
and it's late at night when the body
fires you up in that tires in florida in
florida air
i'm telling you right now i am
twenty-five people i ain't i'm i'm out
lost you live near the sea
yeah the sea
i like to see here man there's something
about the florida that that
humanity i agree i breathe so well in it
isn't humidity good for older people
that's why people that's well good and
sun humidity and you know it gets my
body it's good for your skin too once it
adapts yes my skin's really oily in the
south which i don't enjoy yeah really
really start to adapt yeah but it
doesn't at first my hair gets all curly
yeah look like [ __ ] that i was making
this joke but it was true about like
florida i i'm not when i'm in naples
first of all please understand you're
saying they have it's all white they
have well no but i'm talking about i'm
talking about the everglades when i i'm
not getting out of my car late at night
to take a piss
there's a moat right there there's
crocodiles there's snakes everywhere and
when you say crocodiles it's not just
alligators they're the american
crocodiles got some american crocodiles
which america they'll eat yeah they'll
eat anything yeah and then you got you
got all kinds of [ __ ] here's my thing
have you ever thought like think about
it florida no state taxes
gorgeous beautiful weather yes but would
you ever live there like i think about
this all the time like it has beaches
okay because dope cities when you say
beautiful weather you've got to remember
something
in the summer and i'm talking when i say
summer i mean from now i've been down
there
i played football down there miami yeah
it's a little sticky
it's beyond hot i mean june july this is
the thing about texas too people talk
about that austin is great june july and
august including september in dallas
austin come talk to me no and don't get
me wrong that nobody beats l.a weather
nobody on earth nobody no body weather's
great yeah is the weather enough to keep
you so the reason i'm bringing this up
you'll love this reason for this i'm
going to get my coffee and there's a
bunch of cops up front yeah i walk up
the thick boy my oh what's up fellas but
go blue whatever you know i'm super pro
cop
and they're all i can't belie in the
this cop bald head rough looking dude
yeah he's like uh you know they're
they're on break or whatever and he's
just talking and he goes i can't believe
you didn't follow your boy rogan to uh
it was close man i went looked at
properties i just i'm an l.a guy i'm
staying here and he goes yeah it's only
get worse here
and i go oh yeah dude i wanted when i
left that conversation i wanted to sell
my house and move today yeah he goes
with inflation he goes this this this
city's never coming back man and he was
in crime you want to talk about crime he
goes i've been on force for 20 years he
was in in my area is downtown and uh
before that was compton he's like so
i've seen his crime he was then i'm
reporting how bad it is dude and he goes
where do you live and i tell him you
know i'm like oh there he goes oh you
know a lady just got shot in the face
over there i go get the [ __ ] out and he
goes no it's a safe neighborhood he goes
but some lady just some guy decided
having a bad day shot her in the face
and i go oh it was like a domestic
dispute yes didn't even know her drove
by turned off the shot
just dropped her and he's like it's
going to get worse i was like
well this is why i gotta go
yeah and then he goes you carry a gun
right i go yeah he goes you should he
was like tell everybody carry a gun
jesus christ yeah i'll say what now and
he goes it's never coming back and you
know is this never gonna come back it
was then inflation is you know what's
gonna happen with inflation you just you
can tell you're smart dude yeah he was
in with him he was not from hearings
with inflation he was well what's going
to happen brendan he goes well the
inflation is so bad he goes i bet you by
next when we're at 10 a gallon of gas
which for people like you not a terrible
deal you're still going to drive right
oh yeah he goes for others it's a huge
deal if you're a gardener and you have
to drive your truck yeah so he goes so
he was what's gonna happen is with this
inflation and he was which the economy
is never gonna bounce back from this guy
was super positive he was never gonna
bounce back from he goes what's gonna
happen is same thing the classes in
india there's gonna be the super rich in
california and there's me no middle
ground and there's gonna be super poor
that's great because that's called civil
war well then he goes then what happens
there it's crime well those people
now they're not only doing crime they're
doing crime because they need to feed
themselves a little desperate yeah he
goes and you're gonna stick around for
this yeah and i would don't think that's
gonna happen all over mercury no just
here yeah yeah cause those guys i was
like i went well fellas i'm gonna go
sell my house i will see you guys like
san francisco that's san francisco with
those kind of policies those progressive
policies you have open-air drug markets
everywhere you have ms-13 run and [ __ ]
dude i go i go i don't know how you do
it man i was and i was telling about
that accident i saw i go that you know i
had to talk to a therapist about i said
i couldn't sleep for nights man and he
goes yeah he doesn't get used to yours
like last week we're over skid row
they just side cut this other lady's
head off we pull up and she's holding
the head with a knife what i'm like what
what and he goes oh that's fine i go did
you sleep god no i'm used to this it was
their head yeah this is another one it
was a tent situation and i guess the guy
just having a bad day beat the other guy
to death and uh literally we we pull up
he smashed the guy's head so bad it was
like a pumpkin the brain was everywhere
and he's eating the brain
no yeah and i go well he's not yeah i go
he's crazy yeah crazy i go and that
didn't [ __ ] you up yes uh-uh well this
is now this guy is
dark no all of but all of them were like
you know but they're it's just
we're boys you're a little bit in a war
zone you know but we're like we're all
like guys you know so like because i was
like how bad can it be like excuse me
and then share those stories i went well
see you guys later i said the guy even
brains he's clearly he goes oh he's yeah
clinically insane dude he shouldn't been
on the streets shouldn't be i'm shooting
down the street he ate his brain he was
like that was a tuesday brenden yeah
well now florida i so i have two good
friends that are trial lawyers in
florida they they they represent they're
public defenders
and that's a fun job yeah and i said uh
because you're representing good people
now they're down in miami and i said
dave county i said and he goes it's just
been very tough and i go why because
with covetous people are going crazy i
said
so what do you mean a lot of kidnappings
there's going there's a lot of
kidnapping going on and a lot of uh a
lot of that that happens that ends
very badly [ __ ] yeah and they deal with
that [ __ ] and of course i'm so morbid
i'm like tell me more oh yeah i want the
details even if it bothers me i want the
details but it'll [ __ ] your day up man
yeah and you know what i do because i'm
a civilian i go but but usually they
they it doesn't end in death and they go
oh it ends in terrible sexual crimes and
death and i'm like oh okay and they have
to they have to defend those people but
don't you think and you don't hear me
around nobody loves cops more than i do
but don't you think those cops have a
skewed view or
of course they don't because
he was a living he was like i lost him
yeah it's like what's his name who
survived the world world war ii
and they said um he they said the guy
who wrote where the wild things are and
they said
yeah and they said um
do you believe in god and he said no he
just really casually he goes no no the
war took care of that for me oh wow just
like that yeah once you see some [ __ ]
yeah it's it's like no no whatever god
you believe
i i'm gonna talk about the pod before
when my house got broken new years ago
and i was i was yelling at the cops
because i was i i came in late and i'm
like where the [ __ ] were you guys it
took you 14 minutes man and he goes you
know how big l.a county is dude we don't
have enough cops he goes i tell every
and i talked to the same cops about this
today he's like you got to be able to
fight for around eight to ten minutes
your life is online for about eight ten
so you gotta be able to fight so these
people who live these kush lifestyles
and you know don't train or work out
like yourself he's like you'll be able
to fight for about eight summits before
he can get there he's like because we
can't fight you're [ __ ] well i also
say and he's like and he was in that he
was you know i wouldn't go on records
and i tell everyone carry a gun of
course he's like even if you don't have
a concealed weapon license care again we
can't search your car if we don't have a
reason to so you might as well carry on
have a gun have a [ __ ] boys it's true
yeah
i would rather have a gun by the way
when you say fight back that's what
you're talking about because they i
assume that guy has a gun you're coming
into my house and i'm gonna i'm gonna
[ __ ] i i i assume you're here to kill
me well i was telling the cop i was like
yeah these guys brought my house and uh
and i said yeah and they had gunzios of
course who's gonna break into your house
without guns he was if he goes if he was
let's say three of them broken they have
guns you strangle the [ __ ] out of them
because nobody's bringing your house
without a gun dude so you should
automatically assume every time they
come in there if they do again they have
a gun yes because you have guns i go do
i ever dude and also you want a tactical
shotgun with some bird shot in it
yeah move on you want to be ready for
that here's the problem the ar-15 too
loud simply too loud they're too loud
and they will blow out everybody's ear
drums so [ __ ] cops beg to differ i want
a shotgun i'll get a tactical shot sit
down both the cops said that both and a
nine millimeter cups that have all of it
yeah we'll have zombie apocalypse you
got to be ready for everything yeah i'm
not starring enough food
you know tim kennedy is the guy who's
got like you know he's too far away
from five elk that are frozen and free
yeah he's ready to go and you really get
cash those are the guys i don't know
they're far away though yeah
yeah i got done let's go i need to get
to [ __ ] texas man
well now texas has its own problems
texas got water i care though water
problems and things like that but i
agree i mean do you weigh the pros and
cons yeah this is just i love i love
california man i'll stay here i'm gonna
i'm gonna gut i'm gonna die here i'm
gonna gut it out
it would have to get exceptionally bad
for me to i mean like now shitty but i'm
an optimist and i think things you know
things ebb and flow me too i think once
news comes out you know somebody in
there knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
yeah
i think once 2024 comes around things
bounce back a little bit well you just
you know again it goes back to are the
bad ideas going to win or are the good
ideas going to win that's the problem so
you know right now i think a lot of bad
ideas are winning do you see what
ireland's doing and conor mcgregor won't
harm the pain at the government there no
they're enforcing uh curfews and
lockdowns
because of covet yeah because covenant
because they don't have the resources
for the vaccines and connor was like
we've done everything and more and
listened to you and now because you guys
didn't plan for this you want to give us
care if you don't like downing because
you're asking too much
and this is a lack of you guys
not getting it done i agree with that
and also like how much longer in los
angeles do i have to wear a mask it's
two years now how much longer do i have
to [ __ ]
i mean well fauci keeps pushing the
that's his thing right but also you know
you know how your mom always warned you
like wear scarf in the winter that's
fouchy he's 90 dude so of course he's
like we got to be in mass forever we got
to wear [ __ ] scarves forever you know
it's probably going to happen for a
little while yeah they're doing control
construction
yeah all right well
that's the way it is sometimes yeah
ireland home to one of europe's highest
vaccination rates imposes curfew on pubs
and clubs as cases rise they said
midnight though which i have a i haven't
seen but even if it was 2 a.m i know it
still it's ridiculous yeah it's some
nuts
on our tweets
i'll tell you dude europe's they're 90
of people over age 12
that's insane dude it's vaccinated i'll
tell you i'll tell you the doors i want
on my on my [ __ ] house i i want to i
want a fortress and i found the doors i
found the doors i'm looking for from my
house i've been looking where'd you find
me um
doors aren't the issues the windows go
go to the doors of the supreme court for
a second
dude that's stupid
that's not happening just the windows
dude
now take a look at those doors i've got
big wooden doors yeah and i got i got a
they're actually
bronze but i i got a i got a question
for you yeah are you gonna are you now
you're gonna pay half a million dollars
after those installed well he's not no
that's that he's not and then also
offensive they're gonna they're gonna
smoke you out dude that they are gonna
smoke they're gonna smoke you out and
then you gotta worry about the windows
because that's where they come you're
right yeah but what do you think
one of them not two of them but one of
them what would you say in pounds what
would you say fifteen hundred pounds
fifteen hundred wait it's bronze solid
bronze yeah i think it's your shirts
uh two thousand pounds a door two
thousand pounds a door it's heavy yeah
that's it that's i know how that's now
here's you're a little off now here's
the thing yeah the just the to hold
those doors in place on the wood of your
house in manhattan where the [ __ ] you're
at
you need some
well because those doors are not two
thousand pounds that they're they weigh
a thousand pounds
what's that are they five thousand good
if they're more than five thousand so
each door each door weighs 26 000 pounds
oh well that's not happening each door
weighs 26 000 pounds that's 13 tons
um
isn't that crazy and now and this is you
just want to you just want to prevent
strong hinges you just want to prevent
people from kicking in your door yeah
that's what i was thinking so maybe and
then you can put jail like prison bars
on the windows
you know what's gonna be fun is your
house i can't get out there right people
like with the [ __ ] okay there's a fire
roll do you think that 13-ton doors will
cost some money yeah because your girls
are able to push that open with the baby
that's easy that's hard with the [ __ ]
stroller just open it up you're inside
game set match you're in some trouble
all right nothing you can do i don't
know what you do
yeah 26 000 pounds you won't hear a
weird idea i had because you've been my
house like three stories yeah this is
not your biggest idea but if i was like
if you were like rich rich hold on let
me guess what you're thinking
so stupid wait so so this is for safety
it's it's for someone to break into the
house are you gonna say you want a hot
air balloon
no
that would be cheaper than what my okay
my idea is retractable stairs so they
can't get upstairs so the stair goes and
rolls in like they're still actually
kind of kind of great i can't get up
there the problem and then we just have
our guns yeah the problem is if there's
an electric short and you're on the
stairs and you just get mangled up in
him well that's i mean yeah but is that
a good idea yeah like as soon as like
you know entry level one this year the
stairs i like that idea like if i'm elon
musk
and how are you gonna get up there what
are you gonna do dude was i'm up here
you're down there oh cops are called
we're just chilling up here you guys
can't get up here i was in cher's old
house and i went into her panic room she
had a panic room those are cool in
malibu i have one of those damn
have you seen mine no
i ain't you have one yeah i like a panic
room where if i'm not home my girl see
that's what i'm talking about they go
into the wall
yeah that's cool
yeah now unless the guy does like poor
parkour or some [ __ ] he's not gonna be
able to jump along and like get up there
yeah yeah i don't know
you have to hear them downstairs but
that's pretty cool yeah the alarm
you can't get in my house without you a
door a window a door nothing can come in
without me no automatic thing that tells
you oh yeah everywhere
everywhere tells me exactly where i have
video cameras all over the [ __ ] place
yeah
you got to have that stuff yeah
but not a good idea retractable stairs
you can't get up there
but to your point if there's a shortage
and it's like we're just stuck up there
for the day it's getting a balloon to
somebody comes well no then you'd have a
ladder at the back i could toss like a
rope ladder and we would walk down yeah
or have a generator
yeah but even cheaper would be just a
wooden ladder where you could throw it
down the sidewalk wait a minute that
one's actually pretty cool but wait they
can still climb it huh so it folds this
way it folds back out and in i like that
but they could still try to climb it oh
they're going to get up that yeah yeah
no i'm tired
as they're climbing up i pour hot oil on
there oh like medieval times i always
have oil out now i'm gonna tarn them i
throw the tar over and then feathers and
rocks big stones it's a hard time game
of thrones so bad just get something i'm
not worried about olive oil super hot
olive oil and just go burn this and just
a little your skin looks a little chat
dang
[Applause]
that's practical stairs isn't that a
good idea it's a good idea but hot oil
is a real [ __ ] oh you could do
all that once you're in there i have all
kinds of plans for this first of all
i i
think about what i would do
if i had to fight like a like a gang
that was overtaking
my town yeah cartel
i was like riders i was in utah and this
guy had this tiny 22 with a scope it was
a pistol with a skull a little 22. and
he was shooting that gun
and you couldn't hear it sure so you
could just be hidden somewhere
oh dude the dead head and the dog
hey daddy i'll tell you right now yeah
if you have a 22 and you want to stop me
i'm raping you even if you hit me with
that 22. oh no 22's ain't stopping [ __ ]
it'll stop you no let me tell you why
you know i know that i guess if you shot
me right in the eye no no so so so with
22's they bounce around the old body now
the mossad if you read if you read um
that was that about when
munich in munich when the palestinians
killed all israel yeah
the israelis went ah okay well we're
gonna get you all we're gonna find out
who financed that operation
who did it and they they had 22
um pistols
and they put half a charge in it so it
didn't even have as much gun powder and
they would shoot at center mass and they
killed everybody with those guns so
christian you're a gun guy
um 22's i'm a grizzly bear dude it it
does depend on where you get hey look if
you get hit in the stomach the arm like
no it won't bring you down it will hurt
like a [ __ ] heard that pain i
can do with them so it won't kill you it
won't kill you if you get hit in the
throat the head then yeah the heart the
heart i mean it'd take more than one
it'll go through a sternum it'd take
more than one to go into the heart
because he's a big boy he's thick but
the the bullet will go through his
sternum sir i don't know 22 yeah but it
will get slowed down like once it goes
in it's going to slow down and not go
any deeper you have to you'd have to
empty
him i mean again one of the things about
her brain as it bounces around the brain
yeah yeah
if you get him in the head then yeah
he's done the throat either the head
throat
if i get you in the face you're not
doing anything you're going to be like
you're not shooting me in the face hey
dude
if i'm this close you're so [ __ ] what
are you doing for right here
right here so you come at me but hey but
my thing is why 22 why not you have a 9
millimeter i don't like noise
in the house you're scared to wake up
the girl yeah that's the least of my
concerns
i want to so here is this
it is it's that bobby lee joke where you
get stabbed
that's what it is
and you're like you don't even know
what's going on you're like huh uh those
cops just [ __ ]
got me out they just stressed me out can
it can i wonder yeah
but then you know that i looked it up
crimes down two percent from last year
yes i mean they said they're you know
they're like they're not reporting a lot
of them like night i know but crime's
down two percent yeah
stats are stats i looked up stats it's
dude i'm tired of sleeping on straw i'm
tired of sleeping on i sleep on straw
sleep on bamboo i do do but i need a
mattress i spent a lot of time sleeping
and i need a mattress i can rely on a
helix mattress dude listen they have the
mattress just for your skinny little
body if you're a thin boy like brian
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
skinny or thick body type with the
perfect mattress that's built for you so
they have several different mattress
models is what you're saying you name it
they got it for you they got soft medium
and firm mattresses because i like a
firm mattress sure dude what about a
mattress for cooling me down dude
i sleep hot well however you sleep dude
you sleep on you want a soft medium firm
bed sleep on your back side you'll be
farting we got you covered spinal
alignment whatever they want whatever it
is dude helix is fantastic helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
fighter take their two-minute little
sleep quiz
custom mattress that will give you the
best sleep ever 10-year warranty
for a hundred nights you can try it out
for a hundred that's free daddy that's
right they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will he even
has financing options available flexible
payment plans so great night sleep is
never far away get some money off would
you dude helix is offering you guys up
200 off all mattress orders for the t
fat k army can i get some free pillows
for let me give your ass some pillows
and your listeners go to helixsleep.com
fighter couple a couple of two free
pillows
can i ask you a question bro your legs
they look hard
they look long they look popping listen
dude daddy needed a light-colored jeans
to go with this jersey so i pulled these
out well i thought to myself there
looked like a couple squirrels wrestling
under a mattress no you were thinking is
it was
torrential downpour is it raining
because it's drippy in here it's a
little drippy in there a little drippy
and you're talking about my quads here
these quads are brought to you by
peloton is that right yep i work out at
home on my peloton bike when i'm not on
the road i'm at home in my garage and my
name on there's thick boy prez okay i'm
on there
i like i like a customized workout is
what i'm trying to say dude they got it
all man whatever you want listen peloton
makes fitness entertaining and fun
they have the best instructors my
favorite instructor is robin all right
they have great music whatever you like
rock hip hop country everything in
between can i get cycling strength yoga
i want bar maybe even meditation dude
whatever you want if you're a newbie or
a pro we got you covered visit
onepeloton.com to learn more tri peloton
class is free for the rest of the year
new members only visit onepelton.com
app to learn more terms apply peloton
when your workout is a joy it's a joy to
work out don't work out alone ride with
co-workers and friends it's like my
friend who also they have a skewed view
it's like when you talk to a fighter
about the ufc yeah
they know how the sausage is made yeah
but everything's over yeah it really
thinks everything's heightened yes well
it's also like vaccines all due respect
but people who are very worried about
the vaccine having effects on you if you
look at the metadata of the billion plus
vaccines that have been taken
yes there are cases where people don't
do well with the vaccine the vast
majority of people who get the vaccine
including the booster they're okay
they're not dead they're not dying we
were fine yeah i mean it's not the end
of the world but
i get it but i mean there's that there's
that olympic gold medalist who got it
and that has the severe heart condition
you get that what's it called
the inflammation of the heart i forget
the real name but i say inflammation in
the heart okay yeah me too yeah it's
complicated all right yeah that's
[ __ ] dicey it is dicey it's all
dyches it's stressful but everything's
dicey
you never just wait you don't wake up
every single morning since the pandemic
and look at other property
yeah i do every i look at real estate
every single morning every morning and
and the reason you look around in
california and then nashville and the
reason you do that is because you know
in your heart you're still not going to
leave it it would it would take like
they would have to push like some weird
agenda at my son's school you know like
those weird agendas like force them to
wear a dress some [ __ ] yeah uh
they'd have to force vaccines
oh yeah they would have to uh it'd have
to be so heightened like
i i don't know like they'd have to burn
down thick boy or something like that
where i'd be like i'm out of here yeah
it'd have to get so great like the pert
it it they would have to do they would
have to turn to the purge in l.a for me
to leave that's i love it here so much i
know
that comedy's not the same here it's not
the same it's not even close dude it's
not when you go to other places you
realize holy [ __ ] coming to l.a is a
nightmare i was supposed to do the haha
tonight and i was supposed to do the
laugh factory but i i just couldn't
because i
i just couldn't you feel a certain way
about it right i used to be so
excited to drive down laurel canyon and
go to the comedy store and laugh back to
improv yeah now i'm like [ __ ] that dude
i do the road so much also it's just
like i don't know i talked to sugar and
joe coy about literally two of the
biggest comics in the world that i build
my act on the road now yeah like we've
been doing our boy jack jr is going to
be at the
the [ __ ] is it in jersey the wynette
theater with mike marino you know mike
mourinho
mike's great mike yeah it's hilarious
and he's gonna he yeah i was just
talking to him what about it
i i didn't know he was doing the road
like that i love that he's doing that i
didn't even know jack did a lot of stand
up but i guess he does hmm yeah can i
can we talk about when you tried to
bamboozle me into that cataract
steakhouse chaturang performing arts and
event center hey hey cool
can we talk about when we tried
bamboozling your boy here to do the
comedy at the steakhouse
yeah can we talk about that well i
didn't realize it was so close to levity
live that's an issue
but those are fun gigs i've done his
kicks you told me loved you laughs me
and me and dalia did those
we'll have details i've done i've done
that some of those shows are [ __ ]
done
my
i didn't even know i i didn't know it
was in down the street same street yeah
it's 11 minutes away yeah too far away
too close too because you're going to be
doing that yeah
they're in march or something like that
yeah
yeah i'm supposed to talk to him today
about
about was it december 13th or 14th
the chow house
you're still going to do it i don't
think so i mean i got to do it with
somebody
i would imagine
i don't know we'll see
we'll see
the six chow house ventura
yeah too close for you i told him he
gets it
where would i perform though
in the middle there while they're eating
their steaks
well usually what he does is he gets the
whole he takes the restaurant and it
becomes a comedy club he did that at the
hong kong end it was actually a great
room i remember years ago you did that
yeah it's so much fun i did it like
three times i will say he does put on a
good show
but
well abba
[Music]
yeah
yeah all right well what can you do who
the [ __ ] matt's buddy yeah who knows
buddy come on let's go do it come on
come on just don't ask questions just
show off no where no way no i gotta ask
questions
with you oh my god
what's going on here how'd this happen
the old rope-a-dope well that's the
problem with corporate gigs you do
corporate gigs they're paying you a lot
but you can find you're going to sell
your soul very dicey circles you sell
your soul like oh that's the stage and
this is what oh
and you don't want me to say this that
are you anything oh yeah no i don't like
being for rent some people some but some
people are great at where they're clean
comedy they [ __ ] crush it
unfortunately a gaffing i'm sure crushes
those things crushes crushes like like
crazy but there's a lot of great
comments you guys know you know my uh
sister-in-law she works for a huge
company and every year in santa barbara
they have these comics come
and they're they were naming some of the
comics like they did not do well no i'm
like yeah it's not like you got to get a
specific type of comic who flourishes in
that it's also they're not listening
it's also the sound sucks there's a
thousand they're probably excited to be
there they have drinks
and [ __ ] time did i ever tell you
with justin with caa he they were using
this old rider
and i didn't know that you know a rider
is like what what the performer
requests
in his dressing room like mariah carey
is out of only pink starburst yeah now
my request is only buffalo my writer
says nothing my writer doesn't i don't
have any i don't i don't have my [ __ ]
you don't want waters or anything i
don't give a [ __ ] i just asked for
buffer they always have something you
know but i've never mine's only whiskey
that's the only demand but i hate being
too particular my rider for whatever
reason because it was a leftover rider
and they had erased it and but they had
left some things in well my rider which
i didn't know said i had to have a
standing mirror i had to have a place to
hang my clothes i had to have a tray of
sandwiches hell yeah
and and then were those demands you had
back in the truck
those demands you had back in the day no
no maybe someone else they couldn't find
a standing mirror for me at this and the
guy was freaking out going i'm so sorry
we can't find him
right but we do have a boudoir we found
a boudoir and i said what is that he
goes a place for you to hang your your
jackets i go why would i want that
i was in the writer we have and we have
the sandwiches i go thank you why would
i yeah it was all my rider i was like
i've been the biggest [ __ ] on the
planet
there's some comics of those crazy
writers like there's that one black
comic in the writer says won't we speak
to other black people there's another
comic i know who has to have a pair of
shoes a brand new pair of oh i know that
yeah yeah but that's yeah that's not too
bad weird i'll see for who he is don't
do that to the club though it's just
some dude so just have one of your
people here and he also all he demands
is white air force ones those are like
80 bucks it's another type of [ __ ]
order [ __ ] off yeah it's another that's
just a [ __ ] power move that's a yeah
it's like another guy i knew he was a
famous actor who had to have a certain
kind of tea and they went if it's your
favorite two you know i guess but [ __ ]
you it's like a hard t [ __ ] off that's
why i request buffalo trace it's [ __ ]
it's everywhere it's 40 30 40 bucks it's
so easy i don't need it now that i have
tiger thick but you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah buffalo trace i got you
because i don't like i don't like like
jamo and [ __ ] jack and whatever you
do do you not drink scottish whiskey
whiskey uh i'll drink it all but it's
not my favorite yeah they're something
more of a bourbon i like i like a
japanese or i like a caramel i like some
caramel yeah too
yeah
this has been sitting out i don't like
spicy [ __ ] see how it is
huh i don't like spicy like whiskeys
this this keeps working yeah
what are you guys doing for thanksgiving
are you doing anything
i'm going to new york are you flying to
new york with the kids going to see the
fam yeah i'm seeing the fam with the
kids that's always baby mama too yep yep
she's meeting me she's coming up from
philly
because her family's in philly yeah so
she's flying to philly you're flying
with kids and uh x
no the x is uh
she's she will not be there
but bx and i get along very well she's
got her own thing going on oh
yeah uh yeah that's better for you yeah
is he handsome
my son told me he's tall with green eyes
oh that's all i know i hope he is dying
yeah diamond handsome daddy has money
i hope so me too i hope so yeah it'd
make your life so much easier like you
want that if you have a baby mommy you
want them to find a diamond piece you're
going to take care of them because then
they they don't need [ __ ] from you it's
been a tough uh it's been a it's been an
interesting go yeah
yeah
jim what are you doing for thanksgiving
know how to follow that uh just family
you're just gonna go home you guys you
guys do traditional turkeys and [ __ ]
yeah we talked about this before
we do the same american every year
i always forget america i don't know
maybe you duck or some [ __ ] no but we
add like we say that every year
we add korean stuff in there money every
time in eight years yeah
um little talk yeah yeah are you going
home turkey's important no i'm actually
staying here originally the game plan
was gonna be uh stevie and i and the dog
by herself because my parents were going
to go to hawaii but with the kovit
restrictions they decided
so they're coming to la and staying with
stevie and i for thanksgiving and i'm
going to take my brother and my sister
to universal
the tuesday of that week because my
brother's never been i want to go to
disneyland i asked i actually uh asked
joe if she knew where i could get in
because they didn't have any more
reservations
on tuesdays yeah disney's nothing yeah
disney's nutrition capacity yeah so
they're not doing it like fast pass you
gotta pay for a premium now it's so
expensive too disneyland you're not
gonna get an arm and a leg it's like 200
something a ticket now yeah you're gonna
you're you you need a grand just yeah oh
for sure parking food yeah it's gonna be
a grand yeah at least that's how it is
like because we live in california you
just go there whenever but when i was a
kid it was like once every four years so
it was a big deal save up time you're
getting a hotel area
you'd go there three times a week lucky
we had an annual pass you just drive up
there
him and his mom yeah when he's a young
real young take him three four times a
week oh it's his favorite place tiger is
a true la kid where disneyland is just
your daycare yeah he's like yeah
disneyland what's wrong with it yeah
anaheim
well i'm not saying
meatball you going back home uh yeah i'm
going back home uh next tuesday johnny's
there now right because he had the yeah
what do you have the partner release
party for his uh
he had a season two premiere uh so he
went back like a week early johnny's
killing it man yeah he they you know
johnny i never his brother he's such a
he's a [ __ ] talented [ __ ] kid that
he they have uh his billboard up in uh
times square right now and he's on the
billboard time square yeah uh if you
want to go to his yeah just 1997 when
billboards matter
yeah i know it's so weird and that weird
billboards so [ __ ] crazy like for my
special they're like do you want to do
billboards i'm like
think about somebody who gets a show um
think about somebody who gets a [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] kid that's him
don't wear that coat but look at this
[ __ ] dude
he's our second lead yeah
wow he was on that 50 cent show and then
got his spin off that's amazing power
book ghost power book two ghosts yup wow
yeah he he originally started now why
did you put fire twice
i guess i just commented twice
they're different i get the brotherly
love man i get it my brother's crunk
from the algorithm and he's a handsome
kid huh yeah yeah a dime piece yeah it
gets all the ladies yeah five towns is
he in that too no that no he was making
the joke like where he's taking the
picture above uh such a cool thing can i
tell can i tell the the joke he told me
about that girl wayne copeland
what show he was
he goes dude you were talking about kobe
he's like [ __ ] code dude i this girl
that i was hooking up with i go i eat
her ass all night long i didn't get
covered dude it's all [ __ ] you know
he's like real new york she's all it's
all [ __ ] i was eating her ass all
night long i don't have gopher it was
next day i go on set [ __ ] negative
test bro this cove it's just not as
[ __ ] contagious as you think because
i hit her ass all night long he kept
saying ate her ass all night like a dude
you don't need to keep saying hater ass
all night long did you say okay you guys
i didn't get [ __ ] clothing all night
all right well i went well dude you
should [ __ ] say that on twitter yeah
oh dude announce that and that's it with
you and that's gonna help with it
eating ass is a new vaccine he is also
hey
he was interested all night long take
over dude i'm [ __ ] fine
some guys have to and he's young you
know he's young it's [ __ ] great and
when i when you say that all i picture
is you like actually eating her ass and
she's on her stomach i'm like i'm not
give me that dude look at that [ __ ]
billboard going south from that or
anything that's a big deal
cool and then there's uh another one on
uh
johnny's gonna make it because a talent
is [ __ ] but i don't know anybody who
doesn't like him
everybody [ __ ] with gianni yeah
everyone likes gianni
yeah he's like he's ready
he's a [ __ ] beast yeah yeah wow
yeah work ethic man
yeah he's a hard worker right and then
good luck stupid talented too yeah put
those two together that's great man
that's exciting
who are these guys gianni paulo being
more italian guys oh yeah there you go
it's pretty jacked there you go kid
on my marky bark [ __ ] now is he is he
your is he is he
sam height uh he's like at two inches
taller we're not a we're not a tall
family that's all right no big deal
well thanks for the tank top guys who's
johnny paulo otherwise known as giovanni
hot smoke let's do that giant that's
what we're talking about that's his
brother
yeah they're italians the whole time
right oh you guys are both wait which
one is which one is who gianni
that's another guy we don't know on the
left okay i was talking about brandon
yeah that's my remote that's our
roommate all right brandon
he's shredded yeah tall yeah he's six
four 250.
he's a big boy that's a big kid
i thought it'd be stronger what do you
mean i thought i'd be stronger go to go
to his instagram that'd be stronger
because they were in there lifting with
us they'd be stronger he's also
he has a lot of injuries here and there
sure yeah he's first of all though maybe
maybe uh no need for the uh tank top
that's the only that's the only thing he
wears only thing he wears we'll go to
like we'll go to dantana's he'll wear a
stringer there no yeah
he's all about looking good
yeah all right well he's good
i like the guys so i'd be stronger now
why is gianni on his instagram nine
different comments look at this it helps
the algorithm that's what you got to do
and the more comments is that you
grabbing his leg
no i think that's milo tan
from box bird ninja turtle off it oh
okay how's box and burn doing
i don't know
i know covet hit them hard
they shut down their brentwood uh
location and kept to santa monica yep
well that but that makes sense because
that was in a basement that was a tough
yeah well no the the sap the the lease
on that thing was nuts yeah that's why
redwater was fine but then santa monica
is tough because
well no parking but they're knocking it
down the owner of the building sold the
the land and they're building apartments
there you know that yeah yeah because
we're building around for another few
months yeah they're i heard you know
tony lives
up the street from me i did not know
yeah
and so where's he he has like four kids
location's not around anymore no it's
still there but it's it's only a matter
of time for it's gone but they're gonna
open a location in the valley yeah yeah
that's where you were great i'd go there
yeah yeah i love tony it's great yeah
tony
tony's adapted to the covet because he
does uh
all his [ __ ] online he's a business yeah
he's smart he's a businessman he works
as a savage it was great they were
letting us go like when covered first
hit he was letting us all go for free
let him work out there i mean tony had
some [ __ ] good times we had we
laughs back in the day well he's great
man then then i knew him before he had
kids he started yeah yeah
i had to convince him to be my head
coach he's like man i'm too busy i'm
starting my business i'm like come on
dude you know what's fun laugh yeah you
know how to box help me out man yeah
he's like come all right coming thursday
we'll figure it out and then friends
ever since yeah then he was so pissed
because i was like all right so here's
the plan dude somebody here three times
a week but then twice a week when we
spar in orange county you'd drive with
me so i'd pick him up at 7 00 a.m in the
prius we drive down there yep i remember
that if you could have done it all over
again would you what would you have had
i wouldn't change anything nothing
nothing no it's like where i'm at now
yeah yeah but i mean you even if well
yeah even if i would became champed it
would have been a battle i would even
have been if i would be travis brown
let's say i fought for a title after
that or two fights after that one yeah
i'd be making less money now
i would have stuck around and got what
all the ct yeah that's right that's
exactly right
thank god travis brown beef thank god
the reebok deal came into play that's
right yeah that's right
you just got to follow you know
[ __ ] happens you and i linking up like
thank god dude god dude
it's so interesting that's so weird and
that all happened because nate marcotte
asked me to come and talk to the tough
guys and i walked and i was a coach
there mark i was talking to nate about
uh psychology like performance
psychology i know a lot about it because
i used to choke all the time
and uh
and and i i noticed he was a little bit
nervous in a couple of his fights back
in the day and i was like i'm just
seeing i i just saw some things and and
i and i thought it was you're probably
referring to those anderson still before
i was just qualified
it was actually the one where he fought
the large um
china japanese guy it was after
okami yes that was a phenomenal fight
and i and i and i just um
the trail sona fight after that yeah he
had a run there where mentally you could
tell it wasn't that there was some stuff
yeah and i and before that was anderson
you said you'd never seen him lose
around including you know and i know
yeah and i know he used to spar with the
great gsp too and you said you know i
told you the stories about that yeah i
know i can see him on here but yeah
neymar core is as good as anybody ever
ever ever ever ever fought mma he was
the captain of our team and i and i was
qualified i felt just to say some things
we had a great talk about it but he had
me come in and talk to tough when i was
a coach on there yeah and because shane
carl was there i was nervous because
when i got in there
i was wearing like a blazer yeah he
looked like a dork i looked like a dork
and i walked in to a lion's den i mean
you guys were all these [ __ ] killers
and they were heavyweights big
well nobody ludwig was there well me and
shane were only heavyweights yeah but
remember it looked big you know i was
remember neil magnet came from that show
yes he did yes he did he's about to go
on to have the most weight or wins in
the welterweight division so nate goes
uh guys we're really lucky to have brian
callan here he's a really special guy
and he's going to talk to you guys
and i was like i i can't tell these guys
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm going to
say to these guys about about this
you know i don't know what i'm gonna say
and and uh and i think i just ended up
making you [ __ ] laugh i think that's
what i did and then you had a show that
night yeah and then i came let me and
shane went to dinner yep and then we
and then remember i was like where do
you live you're like santa monica was
like oh dude i'm moving to la next week
like really you're like here's my number
oh i remember that very well i remember
you showed up in a blazer and fake
glasses yeah and i thought that dude can
dress well and i was like jesus that
guy's
silence you look like a giant and
[ __ ] yeah like a like a like jared
leto's security yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly right yeah and you were
driving an m6 or something [ __ ] black m
and you went like this you go i love
nice things
i was like all right all right do that
and you know it was like all right this
guy's there we go this guy's a big giant
guy
yeah thank god all that happened man i
know man
i just saw this like yesterday too so he
was on jimmy fallon and he looks younger
now than he did before he has to be
drinking he drinks
drinks yeah he drinks baby blood or
something he's 49 right 50 or something
he used to live like that he used to
live next door to a girl i dated and i
would just see the most gorgeous i
believe leaving in the morning the most
gorgeous women in the world leaving and
then he'd be there i'll just drive and
stare at him
i'm like how does this happen right now
he just takes care of himself very well
i imagine it's like
botox and he has no
he has like zero sagginess no wrinkles
he's a beautiful man and he's been a
child dude remember he's a child
actually yeah oh i didn't know oh he's
been famous
forever forever i've seen him in a
couple of parts he's like interview with
the vampire dude he's like brad pitt he
just doesn't hate him i've seen him in a
couple of parties and you just see him
and he's wearing something he's
breathtaking it's almost like a boa he's
wearing breathtaking uh yeah where
anyone else wears that you're like what
the [ __ ] came like holy [ __ ] he'll be
wearing bow and like rubber clogs and
pull it off like one time i was wrong
with cameron diaz and he was just that
uh ed [ __ ] i can't remember chris
mannelly who's better looking him or uh
uh liz or elizabeth's son
damian or jared but elizabeth's hurley's
sons like 19. well both of them both of
them have 49 both of them get traded for
cigarettes in prison very quickly oh
yeah yeah but
uh he's um he's a unique character dude
he's a very unique character he's a very
disciplined he strikes me as a very i'm
telling you every morning when i would
leave there would be a different dime
piece walking around the house yeah and
i'll just drive back and there should be
and there should be oh my god you know
i'll drive
yeah and you would be looking at him oh
no yeah the girl already left i'd be
like
that's exactly what you and i would be
doing please don't do that with your
tongue
i appreciate it i fold it
fold it you know jared you know jay does
that it's my grandparents do it and jay
does it it's a hereditary thing
like when jay went
like
guys do that
that's weird huh my friend was used to
[ __ ] bully me and i went before he
was gonna punch me he'd go
yeah i got a [ __ ] here yeah yeah it's
weird with the tongue because i get it
and i always do stuff with my tongue too
you do always always always never seen
you do anything you'll see it on my
special i'm always doing something with
my mouth always yeah when i shot that e
show that big e show like you gotta you
gotta quit sticking your tongue out i
don't know i'm doing it like you got you
gotta stop yeah like it's distracting i
keep my tongue tight and in my tongue is
flat and short look
yes yes yeah this short tongue i got a
very anticipated tongue like a bird
it looks like a guy oh my god [ __ ] you
it's white it's dry yeah it's [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] tongue dude that means
you're dehydrated that's a long tongue
jack big
impressive i'm always [ __ ] around
with it you got a big old [ __ ] tongue
you got a lot of big [ __ ] going on yeah
big dick big mouth yeah
i'm not doing that
nah just nah man no i'm not
nah man all right no man nah man
[ __ ] sasso sent me a
picture of a deer like in the distance i
could just get a giant picture of a deer
distance and i'm like ah cool nature
i love deer you know in the morning it's
like in the morning and then like 10
minutes later i just get another picture
of a deer but this time the deer is
closer
and just a different thing about him
planning this yeah and i'm like okay
there's a deer again yeah have a good
morning yeah that's it
then another 10 minutes just a close-up
but the deer is like now the deer's face
is right it just closed it we just see
the nose
like that i go okay man i see the deer
yeah right there good you know have a
good morning next one him shot i have a
good morning and the next one is just
this [ __ ]
this this
grizzly bear that's tearing the deer's
head off it's tearing like a real yeah
just yeah like a real picture
the same deer and i'm just like he's
like this what i'll do today that's a
[ __ ] threat yeah of course it's
always the it's always the bear or i'll
just get one i'll just get a bear dude
hey when are we going to get sass on
fight campaigning
i keep telling him was he scared no
he'll come on we got to get him on i
love will he goes like this to me the
other day he goes he goes
um hey are you still doing that karate
podcast where you guys talk about stuff
i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude he goes
no but i mean you guys are all guys you
guys you guys are a bunch of guys
sitting down talking about things
i got a text from dalia last night i
just get i'm driving i you pop you know
i'm like on the what's dope about the
broncos it pops up and shows you the
text yeah so you're not going to look at
your phone so it pops up and i just get
[ __ ] this ferrari you know because i'm
the one who got him
yeah he was [ __ ] this friday so i you
know i kind of take it personally i'm
the reason why he hasn't and i go dude
what's wrong with the ferraris it's
always in the [ __ ] shop i'm selling
this thing no dude don't sell it because
i'm [ __ ] done with this thing he's
always in the shop i'm like all right
dude yeah because i guess it i i think
what's happening is a he doesn't drive
enough so electrical like it won't start
because he's not driving enough or b
i think he's [ __ ] with the gears
because it has the pdk and
he doesn't know what he's doing so he's
[ __ ] running it hard like going
uphill why does he get why why did he
get that petite why didn't you tell him
to get the better ferrari that for what
he's looking for that's a great ferrari
the ff because because he can put his
kids in the box
it's great for us yeah but it doesn't
look good
but this one this what i told him is uh
it's a great car that's the ultimate dad
car that's a beast dude oh really i
[ __ ] like i don't like
but here's the thing with that card so
he not only did and for him it's too
much and he knows this he's going to
listen to this a it came with different
hre rims which i've never tried out rims
on the ferrari but for those hrd's adobe
came with came with a novatek exhaust
system
so probably uh eighty thousand dollars
it's probably sixty thousand because
they did headers exhaust so
you left before you started it sounds
like a [ __ ] banshee and for him it's
like you know it's his first ferrari
it's an insane car jesus but the the
inflation with cars is nuts oh we talked
nuts i'm in the car business i'm i'm
getting the i don't see your car
business i'm looking for a car you are
well i'm going to go with the car i'm
going to go with the tesla my girl my
girlfriend's too easy it's too easy i
know but my girl's looking for a car
it's everything's going above sticker i
don't give a [ __ ] like what it is
everything like like even like a
forerunner it's like oh stupid it's
stupid so i was telling chris i'm like
well now's the time to sell it with
inflation with this ferrari you're going
to make money back 100
i finally convinced my girl for that
probably 20 over what he paid for it
really
you know what's crazy right now is g
wagons
what's going on with mercedes is they
don't have the
the parts
to produce the g-wagon because the you
know the manufacturing all that stuff
they don't have the parts so you're not
getting a g wagon for the next two years
the next time a g-wide comes out to me
electric so the current g-wagons the
inflation on them is
nazos i've had a lot of cars there's not
a car i hate more on this earth than
that g wagon why for the price it's
uncomfortable yes there's not a lot of
room we have kids
awful 10 miles a gallon like am i it's
my girl's she's a moth
it's the v8 twin turbo it's the amg
package i'm like this is it's an amg 63.
okay i'm like for what you do this is a
piece of [ __ ] i always talk [ __ ] about
it and um she loves it
it was it's her dream car so i told her
i'm like right now it's our most
expensive car we own think about all the
car zone out of all the cars that's the
[ __ ] most stunning car by far
it's a tank so it's safe for the kids
which is what i like but there's no like
i'm when we drive like to the mall they
would drive down to
century city i'm so uncomfortable the
seats are this big yeah and for that i'm
like come on man i'll take you so
finally so far i told greg oh not even
close what not even close so i told greg
i'm like okay get put it on the market i
was like i'm gonna tell my girl play on
the market let me know i can get for it
so he puts out the market
sold it without her knowing sold it
yesterday sold it and she goes i go
this is this i come home this way i come
home yes i go and i go how's the g wagon
shows good why go um that's cool
i go i sold it
[Applause]
i sold it she was what the [ __ ] are you
calm down calm down i sold it i got a
good news
i said here's the thing not yours
anymore in two years they're gonna
release an electric one when you get
that yeah but we sold that car so you
left the car anymore but it's just
business she understands i got something
else so funny you got some money for it
so the market's so crazy yeah what i
paid for it i got 75 000 over it so we
made money her driving that car once i
explained that to her and how it helps
out the family she got it that's
incredible but the the car market is
insane it's not so yeah it's all because
of covet and there's a shortage of parts
yeah manufactured everything yeah and
then also with the the you know the the
exclusivity of that car they can't come
to the united states so one of the
things that that my brother-in-law was
talking about is that manufacturing is
going to start coming back and the
reason is in america you're saying
artificial yes artificial intelligence
and robotics are going to make it so we
it it'll be cheaper to make it here in
the united states there's also a whole
bunch of like a movement to keep things
back here but yes it's like you make it
in vietnam you make it in china we don't
need it anymore because it's not a safe
you're saving on labor costs okay but
what's happening to get it over you
don't need that much labor anymore so
more and more so you're not going to
worry about the ships being in dock and
all that pollution a lot of stuff is
going to be made back
yeah a lot of stuff you can have i
[ __ ] dude out of all the cars i've
had that i [ __ ] love that bronco has
a big [ __ ] usa flag on it sick dude
it's a great truck great trick take the
top off wow nothing better i love that
you drive it all the time you don't even
drive your other cars i haven't driven
the porsche forever i [ __ ] love that
it's just easier huh it's just it's
easier but it's fun it's so funny i'm
such a take the top off
the big screen
american made has a big [ __ ] ufc usa
flag on it that makes me happy the other
day didn't you post a photo of two of
them yeah do you have two now no
i flipped the other one oh okay yeah i'm
in the car business
me and my guy
climber have a car business
i'd love to have that bronco i wouldn't
drive it as much storage that you would
love that bronco i would right in the
wall
oh no what you did have you posted on
this who's on the store yeah it's a
great though but still that's cool look
at that leah boss i'm doing work
it really is a beautiful car though they
they nailed it you know what ford did so
in all the forums everyone's always
complained about
uh certain things and obviously the
retro broncos are coming back ford
actually listened which car companies
don't they listen when they said all
right what do people like about jeeps
what did they not like what do people
like about the retro ford broncos like
what's doing well and they they
built it and based it off of that
and you got the perfect i always
wondered why they didn't bring the
bronco
i think it's the coolest look it's a
truck they're so dope i don't even like
cars and i was like i love that car i i
owned one i [ __ ] bought a 1973 bronco
worse thing worse now so as soon as i
saw i was like i will [ __ ] take that
they nailed this thing oh it's beautiful
two years later i like the two door that
you have that's my
two it should be a two-door four-door is
it yeah the two now remember i grew up
in a bronco my dad had a bronco eddie
bauer two-door so me and my brother jump
in the back yeah now did i almost wreck
it yeah i did yeah so my dad parked that
safeway when i was a kid he goes i'll be
right back i'm going to remember we have
to take movies back so we'd always write
moves on friday we had to return by
saturday so my dad drove up there parked
in like the like right in front of the
store in the fire lane yeah i'm gonna
run it real quick don't touch anything
like say less dude he runs in there i
jump in the front and jay's in the back
i'll never forget this i was like eight
dude it's one of the best memories i
have because it didn't end well so i'm
in the front and jay's like get the [ __ ]
back i'm like shut up i'm like pretend
i'm driving and it was a is a manual
yeah my dad had the brake and i pulled
the brake and it starts going backwards
jake goes oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he takes
off runs in to get my dad and i'm just
staying like oh [ __ ] and it's slowly
going back into the store behind us the
video store it's slowly [ __ ] climbing
back there my dad [ __ ] jumped in
pulls the brake on oh my god i was i
started crying he yelled at me so
[ __ ] bad
he's like you gotta kill somebody i
[ __ ] told you you know how you
remember negative things that was the
night well my son i don't know if i told
you my son
my son has discovered fire and i got
fireplaces in my house and my son was in
a pyro this is the new thing yeah it's
like i want to start a fire i want to
learn how to make a fire well that's
cool problem is that now he's taking
matches it starts with like i'm just
going to light this mat that's so cool
i'll throw it in there
i hear him say i didn't know what he was
saying i should have [ __ ] paid
attention but he goes down i'm gonna get
the ashes out of the fireplace you know
clean it up and i'm like
what what yeah danny told me to clean
the ashes i go
all right i just hear that i'm like okay
yeah so i uh
there had been a fire burning pretty
much you know for the past four hours
i get i i'm downstairs my dead son comes
down and goes dad dad oh wait now he's
ten he goes uh small problem small
right
i know now right away yeah big little
small problem and i go what's that he
goes um
well it i i so i've been taking the
ashes and cleaning out the fireplace
right and i think that maybe some of the
ashes are smoking and i look at him i go
smoking where'd you put the ashes and he
goes i put them in the in the paper bag
but i put it out
he had he had taken it it was like it
was in a paper bag well he took the
embers he took all the embers
and a log that was smoking put it in the
paperback and then was like oh that
looks like fire and took it outside and
just put it out on the [ __ ] you know
on the veranda goes nothing to see here
nothing to see here well here's the
problem uh it started to catch the side
of the house honestly jesus christ yeah
i come out and i have to put it out
uh-huh i got to put it out right away
and i and i but what i did is i let him
[ __ ] have it i let him have it and i
mean i let him have it like i like
dramatically because i want to feel that
i remember well
then i then i he's downstairs and he's
he sits down i can see him trying not to
cry he's downstairs in his room and he's
crying
and i come in and of course i can't let
him cry and i go i go hey i go hey hey
listen listen listen
i had to do that because now you
understand we learned a lesson and
learning a lesson isn't pleasant
sometimes i go we learned a lesson but
now it's over embers now it's over but
embers are very dangerous and we got to
understand that right
you sometimes with fire you got to make
i go weak when is that serious you could
have died i'd rather him be very
uncomfortable for 20 minutes and never
forget that it's a long time i know dude
i don't like making my kids never but i
mean me and joe
you know she's [ __ ] hitler inside the
house she runs such a [ __ ] tight ship
dude and i'm not the same like this
morning
dude i'm as soft as it gets like this
morning you know he has to wear a
uniform to school
and it's it's gonna be cold in la today
so it's uniform they can only wear one
of two things and it either shorts or
khakis there's been cold out so she want
him in khakis so she picked out his
clothes he's like i get hot when i'm
playing i'm wearing shorts so she tears
into him blah blah blah i might do go
eat your shorts he's like really like yo
easter [ __ ] if you wanna wear shorts
wear [ __ ] shorts so you always get
shorts and joanna says i can't believe
you let him wear shorts i'm like you
gotta let him [ __ ] decide what he
wants to do this isn't a dictatorship
let him learn that if he were shorts
when it's cold now he's going to know to
wear pants like let him figure it out
exactly what i do let him figure it out
you don't need a jacket you're sure it's
also not a fight like let him figure it
out like there's a reason we told him to
wear pants there's only one way he's
going to figure it out
this is the way 100 you learn
most of the time but then i also learned
the hard way let's be honest for the
most part i learned excuse me i learned
the hardest the hardest way
i don't know how else to learn i've only
learned the hardest way
the hardest way of all time i've only
learned life lessons yeah like
you and i had together have learned a
lot of life lessons the hardest the
heart even in comedy it's like remember
my special like oh remember how mad i
was at you when when showtime goes hey
we're gonna give you a special i came to
you like don't do it i know and i went
oh you're just hating on me but you
don't want me to do this but you're like
no no i'm trying to look out for you
dude you only didn't call me for
a year and a half yeah i begged you
don't do a special and i go but they're
giving me a special you're just a hater
sure not like of course i wasn't right i
was just trying to protect you from but
but you and rogan were like dude don't
do it like it doesn't make sense and i
go i guess you guys know what you're
talking about you've been doing comedy
but 90 years between to you you know
your time i'm gonna do it yeah
and then now i'm older been headlining
for seven years i'm like oh my god
they're so right it's okay and then now
i did this next you said to me you said
you see the great thing about you is
that
you you said to me you you text me and
you go i was crazy no you said it to me
you go i don't know why i didn't listen
to you you were trying to protect me
from all this and i was just crazy but
okay but but in my head it's like oh
these guys don't want me to do they want
me to excel but you know you know then
you get that that seed in your head yeah
i know i'm like oh they just don't want
me to flourish blah blah blah i remember
it but my but this how naive i was in my
head i was like well if i do a special
that makes me like them like i just want
to be one of you guys so bad i was like
if i was special
then i'm i'm one of them it's like it
doesn't work like that patience you got
to put the work in stand up especially
stand up to this excuse me stand up you
put the words it's time with you you'll
put the work in yeah you'll put the work
yeah you just do it there's no i've
never seen an exception
correct so that's why with this next 30
i dude not only did i dot the eyes and
cross the t's
i had schultz who's the most critical
comic on the planet yeah i go come watch
my set see if you find any holes in it
come watch the set i shoot it next week
come watch that tell me if you see any
holes so smart cross the eyes die the
t's yeah
don't have me come or anything you
weren't in town oh yeah otherwise it
would have to come
yeah man i mean listen which is just the
way it works there's only one way to
learn you know there's only one way to
[ __ ] learn and that's such i hope
people hear that because it's like
you're kind of supposed to make [ __ ]
mistakes i don't
i don't know
but yeah it gets a mistake to really
special that early but it's also like
that's my journey like my journey is so
different than everybody else it's like
like to have a special on a major
network after two years of doing stand
up that's [ __ ] insane it will never
happen again it will never happen it was
just but you had it it's insane but then
the amount of i was like oh i can't have
that happen again i have to do work so
the other thing is that the other most
important thing is momentum you just
kept moving it didn't let it stop you it
doesn't bother me it doesn't matter if
it sucks okay no my life sucks right now
people are shitty whatever it is it i
just keep moving i'm like tom brady if i
throw an interception i don't remember
it no you just keep right you just keep
that's that's your view of tom brady
yeah that's fear of you no i'm tom brady
that's why i teach tiger i think you and
i are very similar that way that's why
nothing gets me down i never talk about
my past i mean you know i don't i move
on i i don't when was the last time you
heard me talk about like when i was 18
or
20. i didn't want to hear it you know i
like saying i was a wrestler that's
about it yeah
all right what do you got jen
all righty
hey b you ever go to a coffee shop and
you're on your laptop you gotta hope
nobody sees this yeah they're all seeing
it dude not only are they gonna hide
your stuff bro there are data harvesters
who get your data
they steal your stuff when you go to a
selling site that's why you got to get
express vpn you know what i like
obviously you're gonna be protected if
you're searching the web for some dark
arts but also with netflix if you use
expressvpn they're recommending
different stuff you could have a vpn you
could have your address in china
india it's recommended different stuff
you didn't even knew existed dude right
there you go yeah man it's like lazy
fast my location is what you're saying
so you can control all of that stuff it
works on all your devices phones laptops
smart tvs encrypt your data expressvpn
has added benefit of encrypting your
data so you can browse the web securely
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only get access
to a fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com fighter
don't forget to use the link expressvpn
in your truck and kind of like [ __ ] you
know
kind of not organized dude it's not
organized people can go in there and
steal my stuff i wish i wish there was a
deck out there
okay tell me about it get decked the
deck dude is it weatherproof it's
yes it also makes organizing accessing
that's what i need to do so much easier
i think i have 200 pounds of gear hey
guess what dude they got two full bed
length drawers that can carry up to 200
oh thank you whatever you got the
drawers roll out waist high giving you
easy access to your organized tools i
hate to be a stickler but i'm only going
to put it on my truck if it's made in
the us of a yeah and i need a lifetime
no hassle warranty hey man no not 90
made in the usa 100 percent yeah say
america backed by a lifetime no hassle
warranty with second on customer service
if there's a customer service team ready
to answer all your questions all right
getting decked was the best thing i did
for my truck especially this time of
year protect yourself like i do get your
deck drawer system at deck dot com slash
fighter and get free shipping that's
deck.com
d-e-c-k-e-d dot com fighter for free
shipping on your deck drawer system
deck.com
it's the holidays dude i don't know why
people wait till january 1st get the
thick ass in shape well listen you got
to understand that being in shape is a
lifestyle but it's not just about
exercise it's also about what you put in
your body and sometimes you need a
little help to get optimized i don't
trust other supplement companies i'll
say it well why because they are they've
been in the business and the founders
themselves lived on those supplements
took those you've seen aubry marker's
body you've seen joe rogan's body in my
dreams to me alpha brain you want you
want alpha brains these are tropics or
neutral total gut health dude i swear by
it the freaking shroom tech immune
system i need it right now i know you
see this little clap i got i'm on that
shroom tag baby grill oil
oil
keto stuffed mood and sleep stuff for
you gut health is so important immune
health is no duke there's dudes they got
great coffee they have protein powders
protein bars protein bites fat butters
elk bars warrior bars you name it oh we
got fitness
kettlebells
they got all kinds of different workout
programs home fitness programs streaming
fitness for your thick ass audit.com
slash fighter timberstop the entire
goddamn website audit.com fighter ten
percent off everything we just told you
about here we go so the other night
kanye and drake were pictured together
so the beef is officially over so you
know they had a beef right
and they were going super hard at each
other and then
cut that so
drake purposely didn't release his album
until drake released it first and he
released it after him and then they both
talked [ __ ] about each other in their
albums damn yeah they had this weird
beef who did better whose album did
better drake he's a little more
commercial drake's as far as streaming
wise but as far as quality i would say
kanye's is better connie's a better
artist right i'd say that's a deeper
difference
in that picture he shaved his eyebrows
off
he shaved his eyebrows in his head
that's what i that's why i didn't notice
that at first what a character
that's what a [ __ ] yeah kanye also
went out and said that drake was trying
to [ __ ] his wife and it was a bunch of
[ __ ]
well drake was like you insinuated that
you [ __ ] my wife i'd rather you come
out and say you [ __ ] her because you
insinuated people come to all these
crazy conclusions i'd rather you just
say you came out and [ __ ] i did yeah
you said because it never happened but
people come up with all these crazy
theories and blah blah not i've seen and
this is what makes me the biggest uh
kind of i don't know drake in any facet
but with kanye i will say this i've seen
firsthand what kind of dad he is
when and you know i'm a super dad i miss
nothing parent conference meetings
whatever pta meetings i miss [ __ ]
nothing there's only one other family
that doesn't miss anything that's the
kardashians wow kanye doesn't miss a
thing
kim when i was like oh i'm gonna one up
this [ __ ] like she's there's no way
she's making this parent-teacher
conference meeting there's no way she
was at the mcgowan new york there's no
way she was there last night
flew through the night and made it wow
through the night dude she can do no
wrong because she's no i'm i'm telling
you i'm sure they're so active in
criminal justice reform and stuff like
that that she's special all that stuff
is great as far as a parent yeah i'm
telling you dude they don't miss a thing
that's huge
and it's not it's not a system yeah it's
not an assistant it's not one of the um
it's them the
and they probably understand this very
well the irony is that their kids are
dealing with a handicap actually with
parents oh for sure you're dealing with
a major handicap
your parents are royalty how do you
instill a work ethic how do you instill
values all that stuff it's very [ __ ]
difficult i guarantee it's their main
concern they're trying to figure out a
way to bring their kids up to be they're
doing it right though because they're
present part of it's just b which i just
assume like they're not gonna be so
that's like stallone stallone's
daughters they're they're such they're
so down-to-earth
too yeah but they're down earth well
that family is very close yeah they're
close like they're they're they they are
there like he's at home they're they're
just close but the kardashians are close
anything about the sisters like they're
super close yeah super tight-knit
difference makes all the huge difference
that's like everything pretty is thanks
for watching let me pee on my big dick
go for it
let's do it how much do you weigh when
you were born
i have no idea really were you a small
kid that's 11 pounds
small 11. my mom's four
ten and a half
and your dad's what five i feel this
hiker but like my uncle on my mom's side
is like six two so nine years you know
that's how i work but uh yeah i was
always a small kid very light too
you're a little baby i was like you were
always really big yeah well high school
i wasn't like a gigantic at all how tall
were you
i graduated 6-2 what'd you weigh
175 that's it yeah oh you were light it
was light yeah that's not big at all no
skinny mini huh yeah you were you were
really 175 yeah no you didn't go to
college to promote football once
at 18 years old
wow and then when did you start putting
weight on between freshman and sophomore
year i just blew up like 2 30. i was a
late bloomer man super like damn
but you had big bones you had you you
could see you were going to be big
wow and you blew up to 230. i wasn't
like tiger you know how you look at
tiger and it keeps me [ __ ] big yeah
like boston i'm like [ __ ] dude these
kids are big yeah
i don't think i was like that
i was looking at ray lewis he was giving
a speech to these football players he
still looks like a [ __ ] beast he's
still in shape tiger has had training
wheels on his bike for i don't know
[ __ ] how long he hasn't rid it that
much
he hasn't rode
like crazy amount and then all of a
sudden he's like dad i want to take the
training wheels off like dude i need to
buy
shin guards wrist guards and i think i'm
like oh i didn't have all that [ __ ] i'm
like [ __ ] it i'll take him off you know
roll the dice to my kid i'm like i'll
take him off learn to ride a bike within
an hour doesn't need [ __ ] training
wheels anymore
but i [ __ ] up because i thought it
would take him like weeks to learn it
because he'd keep falling he has that
kobe mentality he wouldn't go inside
until he got the bike right and it's
like turning dark i'm like dude come on
he's like nope
kept falling kicking up kicking up yeah
how's that kobe mentality my kids so
that way yeah it is what it is there
will be good at other [ __ ] but i told
tiger i go dude if you learn to ride
this bike without training wheels i will
buy you any bike you want you can pick
the bike out by your bike this [ __ ]
kid gets it that night i go well you got
it now let's see if you do it tomorrow
before school
waking up at five five a.m dad let's go
out there i'm like dude it's 5 00 am
he's like we'll be quiet like all right
[ __ ] you let's go you know i'm down for
it because i want to promote it help
them out
go out there first try does it go on
circles make holy [ __ ] you can ride a
bike goes yeah you owe me a bike like
[ __ ] sake sell your bike
this morning dad where's the bike at i'm
like [ __ ] so awesome he just wants a
bike yeah
yeah the [ __ ] beast man my son i have
to say my son is not a risk taker that
way but you know what he is funny as
[ __ ] a little crazy he's funny so crazy
that's how it goes he's just so he's so
hilarious man tiger's prime right now is
he's a snitch oh snitch little stitch
my daughter my daughter drives me nuts
my daughter tends to be the boss and
she'll she'll
regulate stuff and and she's a mask
where it's a whole thing she's very into
she's yeah you give her rules and she's
going to fall out of payoff down down
the road yeah
everybody has their thing man
yeah and you can there's positives you
can't harness it yeah oh it's all
personality [ __ ] you got a heart tiger's
a snitch and then he's a super snitch
drives me [ __ ] nuts and then he has
that kobe mentality where he won't stop
until he gets it right yeah
he's a very sore loser called his
grandma loser the other day because
because he kept dropping ball and she
goes uh and he goes touchdown she
doesn't know you lost that one he goes
you're a loser i'm like can't talk to
your grandma like that i'm talking over
here she's a very sore loser my daughter
is
you're she is very competitive and in
fact you could even say like my father
hyper computer
and her mother
she i'm not competitive i'm just not her
mother and my father if they're not
winning well they're going to quit now
now she will find a way to rig the game
if yeah she'll be like well you're
cheating that's what i grew up you know
with my brother and my dad the most
competitive family oh yeah the most well
the three of you although we can't be
around each other jay isn't is he excuse
he's worse than me is that true he's a
nightmare really he's a knight jay he
never got a nightmare oh a nightmare a
nightmare i can get over it he doesn't
he's like an elephant and he hates being
if somebody like if it's a comic or a
podcaster talk [ __ ] about like even like
being funny dude he will hold a j a
grudge against them for years wow i'm
like i don't remember them same thing
it's not [ __ ] that dude
what
that was seven years ago wow nuts so the
three of you must it must have been a
situation tough yes
arguments we like to argue arguments oh
we are you to this day
yeah oh you do even oh yeah i must get
nice and nasty
must get nice and nasty
but that's super left we're kind of on
the right that's fun yeah my dad called
me an [ __ ]
uh like we were at in utah this is the
last time i was there and he goes and i
was being i was being a dick i was being
a dick yeah but he was being i didn't
like the way he was stating his case
so i came at him and he goes well and he
hit me with this he goes when you're
ready for facts i'll give you this and
oh by the way you're an [ __ ]
my mother was like all right you guys
and then i was like oh yeah yeah that's
how it goes yeah how about my mom hasn't
talked to me in a week now because on
king of the sting
stevie talked about how he steals red
bulls i said oh yeah it's cool when i
grew up my mom didn't have a lot of
money so she would take us to um chili's
repeating this oh yeah for sure yeah
double down way to go mom it's just what
it is how i grew up yeah so she would sh
you know she have a lot of money she
takes the chilis and my favorite thing
in the world growing up was a full rack
of ribs and a chocolate shake i knew my
mom would get paid if she goes you guys
want to go chili's tonight that was like
our
morton steakhouse at the time is this
such a big deal now you can't [ __ ] i
wouldn't touch that place with a [ __ ]
porch porch uh fork anyways pitchfork
and a porch yeah
so you
my mom would uh take us there i remember
she stood all the time i didn't realize
it until literally i was talking out
loud because they're like oh have you
guys ever stolen anything i was like
yeah i remember my mom going to chili's
and i'd get a full rack of ribs and i'd
get shaken spray you want something else
like i'll take another [ __ ] i was like
eight like i take another shake you know
that's why i'm so [ __ ] fat now so i
just have full rack of ribs i was like
eight full wreck ribs fries two shakes
and i'm like you want anything else like
i'm kind of full i want my brother
those shakes are so [ __ ] delicious
the cherries on top i get extra cherries
anyways
so we'd eat all this food and mom like
oh cool cool so i'm gonna go get the
carp i'll meet you guys out front and
i'm like okay i don't know how it worked
okay sounds good and then
dash yeah we do that non-stop and then
uh so i tell that story and then got
team and then eric goes when did you
realize your mom was stealing ago just
now just now so we i told that story
they made an animation and i post that
my mom goes real nice
real [ __ ] nice no she was i did what
i could i'm like no mom it's just a joke
i love you she's like what's not funny
to me i'm like oh [ __ ] i love your mom
and it was great try to feed her kids
and you turn around do a cartoon
you turned
into a cartoon that's a thankless
[ __ ] son welcome god welcome to the
prodigal song
i realize on my nightmare thanks for the
protein and the calcium but you know
what here's a cartoon for your [ __ ]
effort dude my mom used to bounce checks
like you wouldn't believe like like like
no she didn't care like pizza yeah we
grew up on pizza sure like my mom it's
rare she made it be creative when you're
not do she'd order this large pizza from
pledge brother's pizza yeah and just
bounce the check here's the thing about
but you know bounce checks work yes that
pizza price costs are 70 dollars yeah
because the check bounces but here's
what i love about your mom remember she
might have been committing a crime it
was for her [ __ ] sure so i don't
do nothing taught me more lessons in
life when we go to blockbuster and we
just i don't know what we just lose the
video game we lose the movies and
they're like you owe us six hundred
dollars yeah mom like come on what are
we doing here and like talk to the guy
and then sure enough he'd give us the
video at that normal price that's great
yeah it's great like come on that's
right come on what are we doing yeah
i've done that with cops when i get a
speeding ticket and i'm like guys
i mean would have wanted to go fast yeah
i want to go fast
like i wanted to go fast i had the road
okay i'm always in some [ __ ] car
though if you're in a car like yours
they're going to be like and another no
the guy was cool
what's in this he's like there's no way
this is legal i went you know a brother
and bumped this
it depends on the cop though oh yeah
so this one's for you brendan uh quentin
tarantino is planning on releasing a
bunch of pulp fiction nfts however he
doesn't technically own the rights to
create
uh i believe he sold the rights over to
the production company which is miramax
and so miramax is currently in the
process of trying to get him to stop
really didn't harvey weinstein fund it
too i think miramax is that one company
that's what i'm saying that'd be a it's
a
company so yeah but now it was taken
over by its creditors or whatever
but tarantino is basically saying [ __ ]
it and he's gonna release it anyways and
deal with the ramifications of it after
we uh we'll still make money i bet but
after all the legal fees and [ __ ] did he
buy any no fun toads
how's that going brian
thank
how much no fun toads are right now on
the open you're supposed to put it as
your uh avatar on social media yeah do
that i'm not you don't know what now i
don't want to get people to buy i'm
teaching one of the avatars
look at that dude dude 600 bucks dude
649. we only paid 100 something 120. now
that's if you have number 510
which i don't think we do because you
can buy it right now pretty good though
trading now only 11 sold in the last few
days
okay
medium price 115 paid 120. it's a
marathon not a sprint remember that it's
a marathon not a sprint do anything look
familiar with this
hold on i got to see what toads we have
maybe we have some of that more because
it randomly gives you some
let's shoot out now you bought a lot of
toads and they're i think we should i
think we should cash out i think we
should before we give you money i want
to create our own nft and i want to
release 500 of them no why 500. all
right make them a limited edition
release two of them no because you know
the markets
you need them to trade you need people
to trade them no have someone pay a
crazy amount of price for the limited
edition finding the kid brian callen
you could but i think you make 500 or
you made 300 and now they get traded all
over the world 300 is too many you think
so 200 150
50 50. i know tiger belly has a few i
don't know uh like the bring up tiger
belly nfps they definitely have quite a
few
but i want to do them
right
yeah i think it's nice
and how much are theirs going for
see it's one thing that they're offered
that it's another thing are people
buying them for that
like if i want that founder's collection
and click on that one
of kal island bobby
sold out 500 unique ones
five price rarity
i wonder how much they go for i don't
know the whole thing's weird we should
do some finally cute nfts
i feel like that yeah
sold out
closed closed sold out rarity legendary
let's do a [ __ ] uh let's do a
character let's do a character let's do
your nuts as nft that you don't have
balls to do that i would do that in a
heartbeat jeweled nuts that's your nuts
bejeweled nuts
my nuts yeah we take a picture yeah we
do a likeness bedazzle and we do a
bedazzled nuts and and what happens in
the computer they have these they have
this program where the computer will do
different bedazzles so we'll just we'll
just show a picture of your anus and
nuts from the back
and then they can do whatever they want
and call them bulldog nuts yeah bulldog
nuts nft i 100 will do that
sure she's got your big nuts on there
dressed well don't give people the idea
just checking yeah no we'll we'll do
that let's don't care about people
giving the idea dude it's your tues i
can get the guy to work on him right now
oh that's funny
i'll get him to do it how many that's
brian's on the right only a hundred dude
how many do it really is a limited
edition 100
100 yeah
all right
and stream different versions of your
nuts i like it what does she get jen
you got big nuts you look like a little
nuts mine are like medium sized how many
do we keep though if we release 100 i
don't want them sell them yeah i don't
need a picture of nuts i have it on my
phone
i'll sell that i'll tweet that out right
now
i i sent that to you in confidence
you have video of me dancing oh my god
do i ever so a new announcement came out
from uh youtube headquarters where
they're planning on taking away the
user's ability to see the dislike button
they did that already i saw that today
this morning is it active already yeah
oh wow i went to a video and it just
shows the likes is that a good thing i
don't know because it's kind of good you
know because you know obviously there's
trolls out there but i think that's a
small percentage of people so if people
don't like the video
i think it's good to let you know where
you're at like all right i'm not going
to do this anymore i'm going to change
this you can still view it there's an
algorithm you can still view it on but i
don't know i guess
are you still able to dislike a video
because uh from articles
that i've seen it was written that uh
only the content creator can see the
dislike ratio so for
but you can do a dislike but it doesn't
show how many dislikes you don't show
how many likes but why not just get rid
of all of it just a thumb in the down
and but not not let people know
for the and then the creator can see it
behind the paper the wall yeah oh but my
thing is that that the heat doesn't
cover the hates in the comments the
hate's in the comments yeah that's what
a lot of people are like i don't want to
ruin david lucas's bit but he goes i've
never been called more the n-word than
in youtube comments yeah he's like damn
how do you know i was black he's like
from the run on sentences
i've never i i just don't know why
people comment and i don't know why
people read comments i would not i don't
know you read them but you want people
commenting you that's how you get paid
on the algorithm you want people coming
whether it's instagram or youtube you
want all you get paid off of engagement
that's why
even disliking a video gets that creator
paid okay so the more you dislike
something the more money you're putting
into the creator's pocket yes
you know why i was commenting multiple
fire emojis on my brother's instagram
post
well jordan jordan peterson said that he
never thought he'd make he can't believe
that all these social justice warriors
basically made him a multi-millionaire
every time they hate on him and they run
their whole demonstration his patreon
goes up ten thousand dollars uh go back
to that article for my chin yeah what's
it say about uh
because is it discouraging trolls
because they can still leave negative
comments
um
so it says we'll discourage a lot of
trolling a lot of mean-spared people on
the internet that once i put down the
people's creative work i don't think so
you might put your heart and soul into
something that doesn't come out the way
you want with likes or dislikes
on instagram account i've taken all
likes off and it's really helped a lot
of caring about the amount of people
liking it with not care about i think
because you have the option of disabling
comments on youtube so you could take
that away too and take the difference
youtube tests out hiding just like you
told it from users earlier this year it
says it's been shown to reduce
coordinated attacks oh so people that
plan all that stuff yeah they do rack up
huge dislike tallies on people's content
jesus they do that a lot
anti-vaccine vaccine just like stop
click bait may users have said the
they'll miss the dislike toes there are
loads of comments saying rip just like
someone use a lot of people a lot of
this is foreign stuff too depending on
the
chris burton says he'll miss the totals
that can be really helpful for you to
avoid clickbait you want to really know
how good the video is before you watch
it the 23rd says a lot of time you can
trust you can't trust the tile of
thumbnail correct if you see a tutorial
video it gets it got almost all dislikes
you know it's not going to help you
well that's the least of my words so you
should see how youtube's decision
protects them from stress because
they'll still be able to see the toll as
a creator we don't have to look at it
dude
i know i don't care what they do it
already auto blocks a lot of hateful
comments which is fantastic
about trolls i heard some people talking
like they were adults going bad on billy
eilish they were like she fought you
know i was like hey guys get a [ __ ]
life she's 18. she's great she's older
she's very talented stupid she's very
talented very attractive it's like what
are you talking about
i don't even know when that happened it
might have been a dream i had anyway
keep going look at that the youtube
rewind 2018 has over 19 million dislikes
compared with three million yeah they
actually got rid of the uh youtube
rewind videos because i like re you mean
where you can rewind it
uh no so uh at the end of the year for
the last like i wanna say like five or
six years youtube has released a video
filled with the most popular content
creators on their platform 121 million
progressively it's gotten worse and
worse with the dislikes because
people are criticizing them saying that
you don't actually put youtubers on
there you put people that you're pushing
on and not people that we actually watch
wow but people who also watch this is
like the very woke young
far left like
we want our fave on there this person
xyz i mean i don't know how you're going
to limit hate on anything you know
people have opinions and stuff like that
they also like to hate it's more fun
it's more funny but also if you have a
fan base like anything with my stuff
i mean like you look at when we had
chris lee on the fight campaign i was
telling chris this it's fifteen thousand
to one
yeah it's fifteen thousand one thousand
dislikes yeah i mean so it's like chris
the those fifteen thousand people that's
that's what that's that's the people
that count
[ __ ] a thousand people yeah [ __ ] off
all right this video looks [ __ ]
terrible
they're just like really big creators
and i'm sure yeah that looks super 19
million dislikes throughout the distance
that is kind of crazy
no i refuse
so this video has gone viral uh
two
fox news anchors were talking about how
people do not like woke media woke shows
and they were speaking about the show
you the female news anchor are they
talking about like in you like remember
when you they were the measles they were
talking about the measles outbreak
episode
oh and basically that's their version of
the vaccines and that they murdered the
dad because he didn't want to get the
sun vaccine and then the sun gave the
kids uh measles yeah so this was their
vision
there was that and then also in like uh
in you that was real woke because
remember when they're about to they're
gonna swing for the first time yeah
remember that and then
and then the you the main character
there's like this hamster who runs aubry
marcus to a t yeah have you seen you
i've seen yeah and when he's like yeah
bro i love him yeah he's so funny he's
so he's not intentionally funny he's so
funny yeah he's like ready to do this
brother he's like they're gonna do it
and then we're gonna do it and then
she's like well how do you feel about
hooking up with whatever's name brian
and he's like okay i looked at my girl
go this is them pushing the work agenda
any guy in his head because it's his
internal thoughts we go [ __ ] this that
ain't happening and like but they're
trying to be so woke they're making him
seem like he's open to the idea yeah
that's not how straight guys are that's
why i told her i'm like that guy's
either gay yeah or because in if it's an
internal dollar you're like holy [ __ ]
what is happening here but his internal
value he's like well i guess it's going
down it's like that's right no straight
guy thinks it's fine like sometimes you
know i'm sure in in
in swinging situations all of a sudden
somebody's like i'm going to suck your
dick but that's just not how
then you're definitely bi or something
but that's
let me see it
so people are thinking that this video
staged because of this interaction
to do to the politics and all those woke
story lines in so many shows today you
know i was watching an episode of uh you
where measles came up
wait wait when did i mention measles
i don't know it was on you
what
what was on me what are you talking
about oh [ __ ] another film
what's on you
we never did
she doesn't know she doesn't know she
did a measles and vaccine episode is
this a joke i don't even know what
you're talking about it was on you it
was on youtube i've never had
raymond i've never had measles
holy [ __ ] she doesn't know episode of a
show laura called you
what's it called
you
you it's called you i've never done a
show on me oh my god
we gotta get it so i give up called you
on netflix
there's a show called lowering on
netflix
she doesn't get it
i'm moving on to adele i can't explain
this to you the pop singer holy [ __ ] but
she didn't get it she probably just
didn't get that there's a show called
he's like this show called you he's like
there's a laura ingraham shawn netflix
you and he's probably that's what she
was thinking why people think this is
staged no it's not stage i don't think
he's here she's
look stupid there but also like but then
how could he keep going you kept going
like what do you mean me i had another
measles oh yeah i'm excited i never
covered measles and vaccines on this
show no you hey boomers he kept pushing
he kept going
no it's called you
if she if you don't watch it you think
that that's what it's that's hilarious i
don't think your brain's short-circuited
i just think she does no clue about the
show you yeah it's a fantastic show it's
great
i love that couple the annoying couple
at the beginning
i love them
he's all in shape reminds me identical
to aubrey marcus he really died
the camping episode was hilarious oh my
god i'm so good i don't get it i haven't
watched it he's like yell brothers yeah
he's like let it out he's all rubbing
him such a psycho for the first season
yeah he is one you're talking about the
star the star no he's not the star
he'd be the coaster
travis van winkle dude he is jacked oh
who the guy from the show him really
jack yeah let me see he was like the
heartthrob in the early 2000s he played
the like stereotypical douche bag and
everything yeah he was in texas chainsaw
massacre the remake oh the remake not
not the original he's built like a brick
[ __ ] house yeah he's so funny gorgeous
and he's hilarious without dying because
yeah he's so funny he's my favorite
character me too by far yeah he's so
funny
yeah van winkle he's a stud
he's dutch and his wife in it so and
she's such a typical like that i was not
meaning my girl were laughing so hard
because that's the typical like mom like
influencer yeah like she has like this
vlog yeah
then their friend goes missing and she
does a whole campaign who she hated like
it's so great it's so spot-on yeah he's
jacked in that
yeah man
yeah he's [ __ ] fantastic he's so
funny he's hilarious they get locked and
you know he he's a like a basically a
serial killer and he puts people in this
like confinement that glass confinement
and he's in there and he's planking
oh she's way doing he's like trying to
get to that zen spot babe he's with his
wife it's so funny he's such a crazy
[ __ ] that you show oh it's
fantastic it's so good
i'm glad you turned around yeah i love
it what else you got jen all right so
the ioc which is what the international
olympic committee yeah they reverse
their ruling on the whole trans women or
trans people about how they have to
reduce their testosterone
and the reasoning they said here watch
sniverus testosterone
i highlighted it here on tuesday ioc
official admitted that there's no
scientific consensus on how testosterone
affects performance across all sports
and that role of testosterone is
creating an unfair advantage is unclear
so is it off to the races for everybody
yeah that's how oh [ __ ] that's what it's
saying that's fantastic everybody gets
to do it now we're going to get some
legit [ __ ] competition
if they're naturally
or not can you say naturally trans if
they they're just trans they
i don't know how to say it so if you
transition into a woman and you're a man
whatever levels you have as long as
you're not taking extra testosterone
fantastic yeah
so so if i wanted to compete in the
women's 100
meter you're going to win everything
yeah yeah
let's put a wig on it's juwanoman you
want to be an olympian yeah i want a
gold medal this is fantastic that's such
a horse it's very but
you got to transition
just identify you don't do anything do i
only have to do it for the election i
have to transition no i'm just going to
toss a wig and dress say i'm a woman no
you don't even have to put a wig on you
i'm a woman i don't know just go in
there like that and just don't want to
be all expensive
as if you're being offensive right now
you're being anti-woman no one put a wig
on you're a person that's oh that's
insane yeah that's sick that's sick
all right if only usada would do the
same thing you see the ufc released
their quarterly uh statements they've
made the most money they've ever made
ufc ever ever wow ever
wow good for them
they were around during the pandemic so
yeah yeah
so britney spears is thanking fans right
now for the free britney movement no
she kind of seems like when you hear a
talk she's sort of lucid but kind of
still a little awkward but still more
lucid interesting okay so i'm here today
to answer all of you guys questions and
the first main question that you guys
didn't ask me real fast right what am i
going to do now that the
conservatorship's over with
very good question
well let's see i've been in the
conservatorship for 13 years
jail
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in um so
i'm just grateful honestly for each day
and being able to have um the keys to my
car and being able to be independent and
feel like keys to my car even more
owning an atm card atm card
i'm grateful for that you know it's nice
it's really nice
um but i'm not here to be a victim um i
lived with victims my whole life as a
child that's why i got out of my house
and i
worked for 20 years and worked my ass
off i'm here to be advocate for people
with real disabilities and real
illnesses
um i'm a very strong woman so i can only
imagine
um what the system has done to those
people um so hopefully my little story
um hopefully my story will make an
impact
and um
make some changes um
in the corrupt system and the free
britney movement you guys rock yeah i
feel like we're part of it
seems a little bit we got it
she's been through a lot she sounds
better like she's more real she's been
through a lot well she
because of you guys in the awareness of
kind of knowing what was going on
and delivering that news to the public
now would i want to run on my social
media probably not
to all of them seems a little crazy yeah
she's been through a lot but after that
you'd be pretty [ __ ] up should you
look great she she looks like no there's
all the bad things they did to me which
they should be they should be all in
jail for yes including my church going
mother
oh yeah there's some drama with her mom
yeah
that one's crazy
i'm a britney fan
same god damn man that's why i signed at
the wall do you see my sign on stream
so by the time you're reading this
brittany's been free
i i don't know i i
didn't follow it but my girl did and i
was got a tummy on her head she was so
what
i'm not did you say brian i'm sorry she
she no she did it she's had a tough time
she's probably celebrating pizza and
[ __ ] man yeah
she's just how old is she now 40.
i wonder if she'll start doing shows
again now she's going to make money 35
meatballs
i thought she was young no
oh [ __ ]
39.
well
she's free man
yeah i feel like the fans did it that
documentary definitely did it even i was
like your favorite conservatorship
13 years her dad controlled her finances
them taking her money her mom being
whatever
what are these people about her sister's
a piece of [ __ ] i mean lynn spears they
just went bad on her can you imagine all
those people going back
that's tough like all your closest
people and what did she do what did she
do she just was great
yeah what she did yeah mike
there had to have been something there
had to have been something that granted
conservatives yeah
what was it was it just she went a
little nuts
well remember the whole movement was all
free britney people are trying to read
into it i think we're gonna well anyway
i don't know i'm sure we'll get more
news yeah
as time goes on i'm here for it
i don't want any new tracks out of or
anything just sing the classics yeah hit
me up yeah yeah yeah
what
hit me baby one more time that's not how
it goes okay
what else you got you don't know
this is just a i just saw kanye on this
podcast
and apparently people that watch this
podcast yeah people that watches that he
was like
this is huge it's the best it's the best
interview i've ever heard kanye on oh
there you go really his hair is what i
was paying attention the most
yeah i just understand himself he said
it's like doves he did himself oh okay
and now kids are doing it
and then he shaved his eyebrows
yeah
it's the best interview you ever see
that's what everyone's saying right oh
not even close where do i see it on on
youtube youtube youtube revolves
drinking chips
drink jams
huge ones huge podcast really yeah
especially for the rap culture huge
budget okay
okay i saw this as well a lab worker
that works at merck whoa
oh jesus christ small box you don't want
to [ __ ] with that yeah they say they
found violence labeled smallpox yeah
and now the fbi is investigating it
jesus christ that's they said some other
like sketchy stuff inside that freezer
too yeah you don't want to [ __ ] around
with smallpox that's not good
yeah
15 questionable vials
well at least they got him yeah they
said no one's been affected but who
knows what this is
i will say i'm worried about the fact
that
uh
if you have something like covet that's
this contagious
and it had a one percent death rate
if it goes ten percent yeah man there
how many people that is you will have
i believe it's a matter of time where we
we know now that there there could be
that'd be the next form of terrorism
disaster and it would change everything
we we know it would it would just ruin
it would be crazy yeah fm terrace that'd
be the move if you're seeing how we
responded to cope i mean they they have
these highly charged as we learn more
stuff we do more gene therapy and stuff
you're going to be able to manipulate
the [ __ ] out of it it's tough to do
though i guess i hope it is it's a
spread worldwide it's tough to do yeah
well kova did
a lot of people died
it just escapes alive and then
just spreads like wildfire yeah what
does she have to do alrighty uh maybe
ended on this i just saw halle berry
post recently so this was getting going
sort of viral she's [ __ ] gorgeous
right
jesus christ
yeah she and then i saw her here too
she's so pretty i like i like her so
much we all liked her
oh gee catwoman yeah that's right look
at her man she's a great cat woman she
is huh she's the og catwoman yeah
yeah so she has her titties
from jimmy kimmel nope he's always
trying to uh bother lebron at the games
he's the security guard and jimmy made
him a character on the show but i like
her a lot she's smoking hot oh we all
like her god she's so [ __ ] good
looking man
and well just one more
little older oh yeah i've seen this i
haven't seen this it's a scooter on a
freeway
is it stevie
i'm surprised well that's his own
personal scooter because you can't take
like yeah
bird on there yeah they'll shut down wow
he's going 50 on there
doesn't stevie have like a high-powered
scooter
it
oh he got a brand new one that goes as
fast as a car steve you can also mess
with it bry really yeah you can do they
told us we can do something to it to
make it go faster
they have what limiters yeah yeah stevie
sent me a picture of his new scooter and
butters on it yeah uh
he and i went to corona del mar this
past weekend with butters and we put him
in a basket and just rode around hell
yeah it's so nice sounds nice
it's scary though you don't want to drop
the dog oh he's fine it's uh in a basket
that's secured onto the scooter
all right is that it that's it there we
go kids old school style come see me
this weekend orlando improv when do you
leave third tomorrow uh friday
you're flying in same day it's a long
flight i don't [ __ ] around same day
orlando is not my favorite there's not a
lot to do but let's be honest i would
say it's the worst but hey
there's always jacksonville i got friday
and saturday there's always josh jackson
there's always jacksonville buddy and i
won't be doing that orlando uh boca
raton florida laughing spree comedy
festival december 3rd a lot of florida
for a lot of florida uh i love it
there's a crowd kansas city missouri
improv december 17 18 19.
great barbecue out there not bad but
then then you got a good you got you got
oklahoma you have three great clubs you
got bricktown wiseguys salt lake city in
the spokane county club look at that
spokane's [ __ ] great i got oakland
you know bricktown and spokane are the
same owners yes they are and then
everett the theater i'm doing is the
same owners oh nice yeah yeah so
breakthrough they're around wise guys
january six to eight
spokane county club january
is on the road yeah he's on the road
that is not that he's not funny i like
how you have that week of december 11th
off so for the fight campaign yes sir
i want to do the fight campaign december
18th two for the jake paul fight but
we'll figure it out yeah you're in
kansas city yeah but we'll do it for
sure the 11th with chris deleo you maybe
a special guest there you go we'll see
i'd like to get a special guest i got a
couple ideas you do too yeah well yeah i
can't have it booked but still shut your
mouth oh you do yeah gotcha
uh everett washington november 27th uh
everett theater out there in washington
everett
hey boeing give the workers the night
off so they can come to my show because
that's where the hub of boeing uh
aircrafts is at everett washington's
november 27th one night once you're only
at everett theater then dania florida
fort lauderdale florida december 30th
through january 1st bringing the new
years with your thick friend here that's
december 3rd through january 1st get
your tickets to f8tkz for myself and
brian callum
thick friday is this [ __ ] friday
everybody else can do it on black friday
[ __ ] your black friday it's thick friday
this friday we have the authentic
baseball jersey see me wearing now
and then also the philly one and then
also the built clab workout camo gear
drops friday as well uh get all that
thickboy.com at 9am pacific at
thickboy.com all right kids love you
brian
texting great i figured we were done
we're done see ya